european union leaders have invited
croatia to the table as the country
prepares to become the eu's
28th member state on july 1.
this morning i should like to extend
a special welcome to our colleague
zoran milanovic prime minister
of croatia
accession will see the end of customs
controls at croatia's borders with eu
counterparts hungary and slovenia
easing trade business and travel while
it will not join the schengen
passport-free area
croat workers and services will be able
to move more smoothly throughout the eu
and vice versa the country will also
have access to funds for infrastructure
agriculture businesses education and to
help reduce
poverty elsewhere in the balkans serbia
and kosovo have taken major steps
forward in their quest for eu membership
following a vast improvement in
relations brokered by their two prime
ministers
eu leaders have decided to open
accession negotiations with serbia by
january at the latest
they also endorsed the launch of talks
with kosovo on a stabilization
and association agreement which could
pave the way for membership
in the future